[Music]
you did something I'm told pretty cool
yesterday you want to tell us what it is
you could it must be very exciting for
you
uh yes you're talking about the what
else are we talking about uh I got to go
to Royal spring training the Kansas City
is City Royals you're not a nun a Royals
fan I'm probably Lois yeah yeah eighty
five we still we have a friction over
that yeah so so you went so you she went
and and you got to would you get to do
what you did you take that it was
awesome I you know I'm a scrub but I
they went they let me suit up and I got
to take batting practice with the team
and George Brett who was a hall-of-famer
and one of my idols I grew up when I was
in the Cub Scouts we used to go watch
him play and it was awesome and he gave
me batting tips actual I'm taking I'm
getting classes lessons from the King
that's amazing and it worked I was
stroking him into the outfield
no really not really I was sooo it's
terrible I'm gonna say that's a terrible
batting stance bought at it will you how
are you doing I was just
chewing them just now iodide you get to
pitch as well I didn't get to pit oh I
did what am i sayin of the opening pitch
the first pitch of the game yes wrong
with you oh yeah I mean I would think
that would be nerve-racking it's
terrible that you know and they don't
let you warm up you know I kept saying
has anybody got a glove and a ball maybe
I could get a cut no no nothing they
gave me nothing right so I went out
there cold and naturally George Brett
was nice enough to catch for me and he
gave me the old you know don't screw it
up you know which is what you want to
hear on the way to the mound chair and
so I work from the stretch normally a
lot of guys work from the wind up but I
work from the stretch chair and what can
I say I brought the heat did you bring
the high heat I brought the high heat a
little chin music for who if there was a
ghost they would've got some Chin Music
but yeah what did you what what do you
think he clocked with that with that
ball oh I mean easy 35
[Laughter]